Paris Jackson seeking treatment for her  emotional health multiple sources  exclusively confirmed to ET that the 20  year old daughter of the late Michael  Jackson checked herself into a treatment  facility a source tells ET at Paris  decided to take some time to reboot  realign and prioritize her physical and  emotional health and entering the  facility will help to quote aid in her  wellness plan the news comes after a  year's worth of work engagements that  took the model turned actress all over  the globe ET has also learned Paris is  looking forward to coming out of this  revitalized and ready to tackle exciting  new projects that await her so are you  in ET last spoke with Jackson over the  summer  where she opened up about what family  means to her  besides the food right here and so I'm  just happy to be with them and my cousin  Austin is here too and like it's just  it's love  [Music]  you